.
WE WILL FOLLOW THAT RICH, THANK
YOU.
LET'S BRING IN FORMER HOUSE
SPEAKER NEWT GINGRICH.
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK BEYOND
BIDEN REBUILDING THE AMERICA WE
LOVE DROPS TODAY.
MR. SPEAKER, THANKS FOR BEING
HERE.
>> GLAD TO BE HERE.
>> Bret: AS YOU LOOK AT THIS
RACE, WHAT DO YOU SEE, YOU KNOW,
AS IT DEVELOPED AND HOW IT'S
CHANGED OVER THE PAST FEW WEEKS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, HAVING BEEN
THROUGH A LOT OF THESE RACES, I
WILL FEEL BETTER WHEN I SEE THE
FIRST ACTUAL RESULTS AS OPPOSED
TO THE POLLS.
I THINK YOUNGKIN IS PROBABLY
GOING TO WIN BUT WE WILL FIND
OUT.
I SAW A BRILLIANT CONTRAST OF
STRATEGIES REALLY WORTH
STUDYING.
McAULIFFE WHO HAD BEEN
GOVERNOR AND KNOWING VIRGINIA
WELL DECIDING HE HAS TO HAVE A
NATIONAL STRATEGY BECAUSE HE HAS
TO BEAT YOUNGKIN BASED ON THE
NATIONAL PATTERNS.
AND YOU SAW YOUNGKIN SAY I'M
GOING TO RUN A STATE-FOCUSED
STRATEGY.
AND THE TWO OF THEM ARE TOTALLY
DIFFERENT CAMPAIGNS.
AND THEN McAULIFFE MADE THE
MISTAKE OF SAYING PARENTS
SHOULDN'T BE INVOLVED IN
SCHOOLS.
AND THAT WAS PROBABLY THE BREAK
POINT OF THE CAMPAIGN.
I THINK IF, IN FACT, YOUNGKIN
WINS A SIGNIFICANT VICTORY, IT
WILL HAVE STARTED THAT THE
DEBATE.
WELL, WITH THAT MISTAKE BY
McAULIFFE.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, IT LOOKS LIKE
FROM OUR EARLY FOX NEWS VOTER
ANALYSIS THAT YOUNGKIN IS
HOLDING TRUMP SUPPORTERS IN BIG
NUMBERS.
BUT, ALSO, GETTING A MAJORITY OF
THOSE WHO DIDN'T SUPPORT DONALD
TRUMP.
YOU WRITE IN YOUR BOOK THIS:
ALL TOO MANY CONSERVATIVES HAVE
REACTED TO THE RISE OF
RADICALISM WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WITH THE SENSE OF DESPAIR.
THEY BEHAVE AS THEY LOSING THE
PRESIDENTIAL BATTLE OF 2020 WAS
THE END OF THE GREAT AMERICAN
JOURNEY.
THIS SIMPLY ISN'T SO.
WE HAVE BEEN HERE BEFORE AND WE
HAVE REBOUNDED.
WE WILL WIN AGAIN.
IS YOUNGKIN TAPPING INTO
SOMETHING THAT CROSSES THAT
LINE, THAT IS A BLUEPRINT FOR
THE MIDTERMS, PERHAPS?
>> ONE OF THE THINGS I DON'T
THINK ANY OF US FULLY
APPRECIATED IS THAT THE VERY
WELL-EDUCATED VOTER WHO TENDED
TO VOTE FOR BIDEN AND AGAINST
TRUMP, IS ALSO THE VOTER WHO
CARES THE MOST ABOUT THEIR
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION.
AND SO WHEN YOU GET INTO THE
SUBURBS AND YOU START GETTING
INTO THINGS AS WE SAW WITH
LOUDOUN COUNTY AND FAIRFAX
COUNTY, ALL OF THE SUDDEN IT'S
THE VERY -- IT WILL BE
FASCINATING TO SEE WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE WHEN WE GET THE VALUE
VOTES.
BUT I THOUGHT LIKE THE THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO SHOWED UP IN LOUDOUN
COUNTY OVER THE SCHOOL ISSUE,
MANY OF THOSE WOULD NORMALLY
HAVE BEEN DEMOCRATS.
BUT THEY ARE NOW SO FRIGHTENED
ABOUT THEIR CHILD'S FUTURE THAT
AS PARENTS, THEY ARE PROBABLY
VOTING FOR YOUNGKIN, AND THE
YOUNGKIN PEOPLE HAVE BEEN VERY
SMART.
THE NUMBER OF SIGNS CALISTA AND
I SAW TODAY WENT TO VOTE PARENTS
FOR YOUNGKIN.
THAT'S A VERY SMART, CUTS ACROSS
ALL PARTY LINES.
PARENTS IDENTIFY AS PARENTS.
A LOT MORE THAN THEY IDENTIFY AS
PARTISANS.
>> Bret: McAULIFFE WAS FACING
HEADLINES WITH BIDEN APPROVAL
GOING DOWN WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING
ON CAPITOL HILL, WHICH IS KIND
OF A MESS LEGISLATIVELY.
HOW MUCH DO YOU THINK THAT IS A
FACTOR AS OPPOSED TO WHAT YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT HERE, THE
STUDENTS, PARENTS, REALLY A
COMMONWEALTH ISSUE?
>> I THINK THAT WOULD NOT HAVE
DEFEATED McAULIFFE.
AND, AGAIN, I WANT TO SEE THE
VOTES BEFORE I TALK TOO
CONFIDENTLY ALTHOUGH I DO THINK
YOUNGKIN IS GOING TO WIN.
I THINK THAT THE MISTAKES MADE
BY McAULIFFE.
THE ELECTRIFYING MOMENT WHEN HE
SAID PARENTS SHOULDN'T HAVE A
ROLE IN SCHOOLS, AND THE
YOUNGKIN PEOPLE WERE GOOD ENOUGH
WITHIN 12 HOURS THEY HAD A
COMMERCIAL UP THAT HAD JUST HAD
McAULIFFE AND PEOPLE LOOKED AT
THAT AND THOUGHT WELL, THAT'S
CRAZY.
AND THEN THIS WEEKEND, AND AS
SOMEBODY WHO HAS STUDIED
POLITICS A LONG TIME AND
PRACTICED IT A FAIR AMOUNT.
UNDERWHY HE WOULD SAY THERE ARE
TOO MANY WHITE TEACHERS BECAUSE
IT'S A RACIST COMMENT.
AND IT'S ALSO MISUNDERSTANDS
NORTHERN VIRGINIA.
NORTHERN VIRGINIA IS NOT JUST
BLACK AND WHITE.
I MEAN IT'S KOREAN, IT'S
VIETNAMESE, IT'S CHINESE.
IT'S LATINO.
>> WE HAVE COMPLICATED WORLD OUT
THERE.
I THINK WE WANT GOOD TEACHERS OF
ANY BACKGROUND NOT BAD TEACHERS
OF ANY BACKGROUND.
>> IF HE FALLS SHORT, AND IT'S A
VERY TIGHT RACE, MAYBE IT'S NOT
EVEN DECIDED TONIGHT, AND, YOU
KNOW, HEADING IN THIS WAS A
TIGHT RACE, IS THERE A RISK THAT
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS ARE GOING
TO SAY HERE WE GO AGAIN?
>> I THINK IF IT'S A VERY CLOSE
RACE, AND ABOUT 3:00 IN THE
MORNING McAULIFFE MAGICALLY
FINDS FIVE EXTRA PRECINCTS, THEN
I THINK YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE A
HUGE BACKLASH ACROSS THE WHOLE
COUNTRY.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, I HAVE ALWAYS
HAD THE POSITION YOU HAVE TO WIN
BIG ENOUGH THEY CAN'T STEAL IT
THE BURDEN ON ANY REPUBLICAN IS
TO NEVER GET TO A CLOSE RACE IF
YOU CAN AVOID IT.
I THINK PROBABLY YOUNGKIN WILL
DO THAT.
HE IS A VERY ATTRACTIVE
PERSONALITY.
HE CLEARLY HAS BEEN HAVING MORE
AND MORE FUN.
I WATCHED THEM VARIOUS PLACES
GOING.
YOU SEE THEM DANCING, SEE HIM
LAUGHING.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW THAT CHANGES
THE DYNAMIC, AT THE END,
ESPECIALLY.
>> I THINK.
SO AND I THINK -- I PERSONALLY
BELIEVE PEOPLE LIKE POLITICIANS
THAT THEY LIKE AND I THINK THAT
McAULIFFE IS A VERY SMART GUY.
GREAT PROFESSIONAL POLITICIAN
FOR OVER 40 YEARS.
McAULIFFE LOOKED WORRIED AND
SCARED AND A LITTLE ANGRY.
AND HE WAS -- SOMEBODY SAID
TODAY I THINK MAYBE THE POST OR
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" THAT HE HAD
RUN A DARK CAMPAIGN.
NOW, ATTACKING ABOUT
JANUARY 6TH.
ATTACKING ABOUT TRUMP.
AND SO FORTH.
AND YOUNGKIN INCREASINGLY WAS
RUNNING A HAPPY CAMPAIGN.
AND I THINK AS A GENERAL RULE IN
AMERICAN POLITICS, HAPPINESS
BEATS DARKNESS WHEN YOU GET INTO
THESE KIND OF RACES.
AGAIN, I AM GOING TO BE WATCHING
YOU AS YOU GO AND START THE
COUNT.
>> Bret: GET THE RAW DATA.
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A
FAIRLY LONG EVENING.
WE SHOULD MENTION THE NATIONAL
LEVEL, THE NEW JERSEY RACE HAS
CLOSED SUBSTANTIALLY.
IT'S GOING TO BE INTERESTING.
THE MINNEAPOLIS VOTE ON
ABOLISHING THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
IN THE MIDDLE OF A CRIME WAVE IS
GOING TO BE A VERY INTERESTING
TEST THERE ARE A LOT OF
INTERESTING THINGS GOING ON OUT
THERE.
>> Bret: FASCINATING.
MR. SPEAKER, THANK Y